معنا من غلاف غزه مراسلنا الياس كرام
الياس اهلا بك اذا صوت انفجارات دوت قبل
قليل وسمعت من الضواحي الشماليه لقطاع غزه
ما الذي تتمكنون من معرفته بخصوص ما يجري
هناك من موقعكم
الياس بالفعل مريم القصف المدفعي كان شديد
وما زال متواصلا حتى الدقائق الاخيره
وواضح بانه يستهدف المناطق الشماليه او
الضواحي الشماليه لمدينه غزه حيث قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه عمق من عملياته
العسكريه في حيي الدرج والتفاح هذين
الحيين الذي بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي نشاطا
عسكريا فيه كما يصفه في الايام الماضيه
هذا بالاضافه الى قصف مدفعي متواصل ايضا
على المخيمات الوسطى لقطاع غزه كالبيج
والنصيرات حيث ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا
قال انه بدا هجوما اي عسكريا على البريج
وهذه المناطق في الايام ال الماضيه واضح
بان كل الجبهه مشتعله هنالك ايضا طيران
يحوم في اجواء المنطقه سواء كان ذلك
المقاتلات الاسرائيليه التي تحوم بكثافه
في اجواء المنطقه الشماليه او طائرات
المروحيه التي تحلق قريبا من السياج
الامني على علو منخفض احيانا وتطلق
الصواريخ باتجاه اهداف بعينها المعارك على
اشدها في كل المناطق حقيقه وكان قطاع غزه
وحده قتاليه واحده ليس كما كان يعتقد
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه يمكنه ايه تقسيم
هذه المناطق او هذه او القطاع الى محاور
قتال مختلفه من ناحيه الشده ومن ناحيه
التعمق والتوغل واضح بان المناطق الشماليه
ما زالت تشهد مق مقاومه شرسه وعنيفه من
جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهي ما زالت
تكبد الجيش الاسرائيلي خسائر بالارواح
وبالع تد ونحن نرى بان الاشتباكات ت تجري
حتى في المناطق الشماليه في اقصى المناطق
الشماليه مريم اي بيت لاهيا وبيت حنون هذه
المناطق التي اجتاحها الجيش الاسرائيلي في
اول ايام العمليه البريه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يعترف حتى في بياناته الرسميه
انه ما زال يواجه مقاومه حتى في حي
الشجاعيه والاحياء الاخرى التي كان اعلن
السيطره العمليات عليها في الايام القليله
الماضيه منطقه جحر الديك والمغر وكذلك
المخيمات الوسطى تشهد عمليه
عسكريه متواصله من جانب القوات
الاسرائيليه ولكن واضح بان التركيز الان
من جانب الجيش الاسرائيلي هو على المنطقه
الجنوبيه على منطقه خان يونس حيث كان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلن ليله امس بانه
دفع بلواء سادس الى منطقه خانيونس اذا
هنالك الان سته الويه تعمل عسكريا في
منطقه خان يونس في مدينه خان يونس وحدها
مدعومه بوحدات من المدرعات ووحدات من
الهندسه وبقص جوي وبحري متواصل واسناد من
المدفعيه الثقيله في منطقه غلاف غزه اضافه
واء اخر الى العمليات العسكريه في منطقه
من منطقه خانيونس يؤكد مريم على ان
العمليه العسكريه هناك معقده ومركبه وان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ربما يكون في مازق ولم
يتمكن حتى الان من حسم المعركه هناك على
الاطلاق الياس كرا من غلاف غزه سنعود اليك
لمتابعه التطورات المستمره لديك شكرا
جزيلا لك حتى
الان